I gotta ask you any more of Friday's
movies I mentioned it in in your intro
and I'm thinking such popular phrase
movies are so popular what about making
another one then I would love to make
another Friday movie but it's kind of
caught up in a lot of red tape you know
I mean well new line in there there with
Time Warner you know I'm saying yeah and
I just don't think Time Warner
understands the value of Friday you know
what I mean I think there's kind of
corporate you know I'm saying there at
the top up there right and they just are
not hearing that the people want to know
the Friday and I don't know why because
they play the damn thing on HBO or
whatever every day I'm weak right so I
don't know why they won't you know say
yeah let's do this
give me everything I need we could bring
another fight do you guys want another
Friday
[Applause]
I think I think they've heard the people
the people have spoken you know it's
gonna help out it's gonna happen now I'm
confident it better all right let me ask
you this you and I have worked together
in a few sort of TV comedy little skits
in here they go on line people really
like him which begs the question when
are you giving me a part when you're
gonna give me something to do in a movie
begs the question Andy when do I get
what if I could be in a I could be in a
Friday movie if you made another one why
couldn't I be in one yeah you know what
I think I think I think I got the
perfect role for you you do yeah you'd
play the white guy who comes to the hood
to buy weed
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you